hello everybody and welcome to a new
episode of archive insights so for this
week I find a really cool paper on
archive and it's titled investigating
human priors for playing video games the
basic question in this paper that the
authors want to investigate is why are
humans so good at understanding and
solving new complex environments that
they've never seen before take this game
for example any typical human would need
about one minute to actually figure out
that you have to climb the stairs get
all the way to the top of the level jump
over the enemy and then get to the
princess in order to finish the level
but if you take any of the
state-of-the-art reinforcement learning
algorithms that we have available now
today so the very best ones they would
need about 4 million frames in order to
solve this level successfully and
consistently and if you calculate those
4 million frames if you recalculate that
into human time if you take a game
engine running at about 30 frames per
second that amounts to about 37 hours of
non-stop playing so that's about 2,000
times slower than any human being and so
the whole question in this paper is why
are humans so good at this and obviously
you would say well that's because we
have a lot of prior information we know
that ladders are to be climbed and that
faces that don't smile are probably not
that friendly so you might not want to
run into them but the whole question in
this paper was how important are each of
those different priors and is there a
way to quantify the effects that these
things have on our learning ability my
name is Xander and welcome to another
episode of archive insights
[Laughter]
[Music]
so in the last few years a lot of very
significant progress has been made in
machine learning and also very
specifically in the subfield of
reinforcement learning
most of these advances come from brick
research entities like google deepmind
open AI and large universities at the
forefront of AI research and so these
advances show us that we're now able to
train agents that are able to learn very
complicated behavior in dynamic
environments using what we call a reward
signal so instead of showing this agent
specific examples of what actions it
should take in a given situation this is
what we call supervised learning instead
this agent is free to act in the
environment any way that it wants but it
has a signal the reward signal that it
tries to optimize over time and so these
algorithms they've actually shown some
very impressive results in a wide
variety of tasks that has caused many
people to claim that we might be seeing
the very early seeds of general AI but
despite these very impressive
achievements we are still very very far
away from achieving anything that is
close to human level learning
performance so our algorithms that we
have right now they're very good at
general learning but they have what we
call a very bad sample efficiency and
that basically means that you need to
give them a lot of training frames
before they are able to figure out what
behavior is actually desired in this
environment and to explain this
difference between our algorithms and
human performance a lot of researchers
are not pointing to the embedded
knowledge that humans bring to a new
tasks that allows us to find optimal
solutions to a given problem much faster
than any algorithm that we currently
have and so before we dive into the
paper itself let's look at some very
funny examples of the things we already
know about human psychology so one of
the things that we figured out very
early on is that newborn babies they
actually have this tendency for
imitation so if a father will stick out
his tongue
then even though the child has no idea
what's going on we will see that very
often they will imitate this action so
that is some something that we have
embedded in our genetics and then we
also have this
strong tendency to pay attention to
faces so a new board child if given a
lot of images will always look at the
faces first and then there are also some
human priors that are not really built
into us genetically but that we learn at
a very young age one of these examples
is object permanence
so object permanence points to the fact
that if you have a given object and the
object is suddenly hidden from sites
that we know that that object is still
there and she wonders what did you do
near what was I don't know where they
went wow that is amazing it is
incredible if it if it's not there it
doesn't exist a freaking genius and
human babies the concept of object
permanence usually arises at the age of
about two months whereas in chimpanzees
and other monkeys this arises much much
faster much earlier so here you can see
a monkey which has exactly the same age
as the human baby and you can see that
in this monkey the concept of object so
in order to test the presence and the
influence of different kinds of human
priors what the researchers did is they
took the game but then they deliberately
replaced some of the game objects with
random textures and the idea is that if
you do this cleverly you can actually
mask away some forms of prior knowledge
and then look at the performance change
by human players to figure out which
forms of prior knowledge are actually
very crucial in solving a game like this
and before we go further I would like
all of you to just click on the link
below and try one of the adjusted game
versions to see how difficult that
actually is if you are deprived of your
prior knowledge and as you'll see it's
not that easy so with the original game
without any texture remapping a typical
human needs about 1.4 minutes to solve
the level the first adjustment to the
game was changing the object semantics
so what they did is that instead of
seeing a key or a door the human players
would simply see a square of uniform
color so what this does is that it takes
away our prior knowledge about the
properties of an object and we was very
obvious is that in your
original version all the human players
reached the key first and then went to
the door whereas in the remap textures
that was no longer the case so this
clearly shows that humans use their
prior knowledge of objects to guide
their actions after remapping the
textures the average game time went up
from 1.4 minutes to about 4 point 4
minutes in the second adjusted game
version the researchers decided to
simply hide the object locations
altogether so now all the places where
the player can freely move around have
been masked by a square of uniform color
and in this version of the game the
average time for human players to solve
the level went up to 9 minutes we didn't
know where objects were but we're still
pretty clear what the terrain looked
like we knew where the platforms were
and where the lattice work in the new
version of the game they remap all of
those textures as well and we call this
removal of affordance and it turns out
that removing affordance is not as bad
as removing object semantics and then at
the end the researchers decided they
wanted to go hardcore mode so they
rotated gravity by 90 degrees they
switched the left and right control keys
and they remapped all of the affordance
textures and well you know even the game
designers themselves couldn't solve the
level anymore
point proven we got it guys so by
quantifying the effects of these
adjusted game versions on the human
player time they were able to list up
some of the priors that are present in
human beings and how important they can
be for solving a task like this and so
we can see from this result that
something as simple as just knowing what
an object is can be very crucial for
solving a complex environment and then
the researchers did something really
interesting
they used a state of the art
reinforcement learning algorithm called
a3c to try and solve the same adjusted
game versions that the human players had
seen and it turns out that the
reinforcement learning agents had no
problem whatsoever with the adjusted
versions where the priors were removed
even in the game version where all of
the object textures were remapped the
reinforcement learning agent needed
about exactly the same amount of
training frames in order to solve this
level just wrap things up humans use
very strong priors that allow them to
quickly discover optimal solutions
in situations they've never been before
and this is the main thing that is
currently lacking in our reinforcement
learning algorithms is that they don't
have this pre build knowledge about how
the world works as a final note though I
want to include that object priors are
not always a good thing if you think
about the alphago system that I dealt
with previously you can very clearly see
that by having this algorithm trained
from scratch and therefore getting rid
of this prior where it's sort of based
on human knowledge and human gameplay it
can actually reach a better performance
there are other examples as well that if
you switch the gravity of the game then
humans will all of a sudden make very
very bad decisions and do much worse
than an objective agent that doesn't
have this predefined notion of physics
and so this shows that while human
priors can be very efficient at solving
novel tasks in new environments they can
also be a hindrance and I think that
this is something we are seeing in
quantum physics right now where our
human knowledge that we have gathered
over many many years of science and
living in the natural world is sort of
being defied by these very strange laws
in quantum mechanics that are very very
unnatural to us and therefore also very
difficult I'd like to thank the
researchers for a very interesting paper
I hope everybody learned something and
I'd love to see you again in the next
episode of archive insights
[Music]